[Music]
hello everybody hello everybody
great my name is Chris Leben and
together with Justin lawyer we are
product managers on Google cloud and
we'll be talking to you about machine
learning on GCP so I'm a very
transparent person I'm going to make it
very clear what I hope your takeaways
are from this talk one I want you to be
really excited about what you could do
with machine learning to I want you to
feel confident that your organization
can successfully implement machine
learning with Google cloud and three I
want you to trust that with Google a is
focus that we are the right platform and
partner for your mo workloads three
takeaways and this is what we're gonna
be talking about for you to get those
takeaways before we dig into it I just
want to say thank you we all have
limited time with our busy lives you've
chosen to come to Google cloud our next
conference in this session so just thank
you so what can ml do for you it could
do a lot of amazing things if your
organization has any competition I
guarantee they're looking at ml now ml's
not necessarily for inventing the insane
if you're in transportation it's not
about how are we going to create
teleportation it's about taking your
existing businesses and processes and
being able to reimagine and reinvent
what you're doing today there's three
kind of big areas that ml could help
with they could help you get insights or
your customers it could help you
innovate your products and help with
automation let's look at automation real
quick self-driving trucks and cars
taking the businesses that everyone's
doing today with transportation and cabs
and making it faster and cheaper and
easier and safer
let's look at innovation one of our
customers Disney uses our product auto
ml to innovate their retail service they
wanted their user experience to be
really quick to find the product they're
looking for so you used a web interface
to create a custom model no ml expertise
needed and now in their search
experience you could type Mickey Mouse
on the beach and it finds all the
products related to the beach and Mickey
Mouse really cool really easy and
insights let's say you're a plane
manufacturer or an airline and you
really care about safety
thanks to IOT there's tons of data that
these instruments are doing and what if
you collect that data what if you
process it and what if you could predict
that maybe there's a part on the plane
that needs maintenance before its
regularly scheduled insights for safety
so feel excited about what your
organization can do so show of hands who
here their organization is looking into
machine learning today great one more
show of hands who here things they
understand what machine learning is okay
about half of you
last question who knows what a machine
learning model is okay most of you so
I'll just touch over this really briefly
machine learning is about data and
taking data and getting insights in
action there's all kinds of data out
there images unstructured text
relational databases sequence
information and what machine learning is
is taking that data taking an ml
algorithm of various sorts and passing
through that data through that algum
algorithm with a huge set of
infrastructure and as you pass that data
through the machine learning model is
created and this model gets better and
better the more data the better
algorithms the more infrastructure and
you use that model to create insights
automation and innovation so we we all
know this service web search
Google's been an AI company and the data
company for 18 years now collecting the
world's data making it accessible and
usable by all and we have a lot of
expertise in this area large-scale data
centers AI experts data experts and what
Google Cloud is is about bringing that
expertise to you with ml this is a nice
little story about how we internally
have implemented ml successfully our
internal AI team called brain they
create ml models take a bunch of data
through an algorithm pass it through a
huge scale of infrastructure and create
ml models but not every single software
developer at Google is an ml expert so
what we've done is we went around to our
software developers and trained them
here's how you could implement ml with
these existing models so what this graph
is showing is the number of source code
repositories that our developers are
using the brains ml model to implement
successfully AI into internal services
external products and we're bringing
these types of concepts to Google cloud
on the right you'll see a bunch of
products that have integrated ml and AI
I'm not gonna talk about all of them
I'll talk about to my favorites so I'm a
father I have three kids and I take a
lot of digital photos of my kids the
ridiculous amount maybe a hundred
thousand in total and I had this Mac and
I had some hard drives and I was worried
about storage so I got Google photos
free unlimited storage that's great
cheap its scalable I don't got to worry
about backing things up but really the
innovation was the search feature it has
facial recognition and knows who my kids
are I can click on a picture of my face
my phone type in a word like a beach or
a boat and now it goes through a hundred
thousand photos and finds the exact
photo I'm looking for in the past I
would have taken me 20 minutes to find
ML is innovating and so could you so no
matter what size your organization is no
matter what type of technical staff
there's different ways to implement ml
and we're going to be talking about both
ways the first way is to use our ml
models
you don't need to be an expert youse
need to be a software developer or your
organization taste does any programming
language on with the rest api simple to
use if you're a CX out there or
executive trying to decide do i fund a
project it's very low risk to take the
high quality model have a software
developer use an API and implement it
get started really quickly and the other
out is to build the custom model maybe
you're a domain expert in your space or
you have access to the data and you want
to create your own in my model so we
have a bunch of tools for experts a
bunch of hardware to get you fast and
cheap ml processing and this is where
I'm gonna hand it off to Justin and he's
gonna talk about these in a little bit
more detail thanks Chris so thanks very
much for coming today we're gonna talk
about how do you find the right tools
for your job as a an expert in your
field so first of all is as Chris was
mentioning Google has created a lot of
machine learning models for specific
applications to power Google
applications and so we then I wrapped
REST API surround these for you to
consume we call these some perception
api's because they're typically around
human perception and how the user
interacts with the application so
quickly going on to the next slide here
there are three main categories of these
api's one is for regarding site the
other is around conversation and the
third one is around language I think
it's important to maybe walk through
each of these really quickly so you can
kind of understand out-of-the-box
capabilities and you can get without you
doing any coding other than using a REST
API and then implement that into your
application so first of all for site say
you've got an image and you want to
understand what's in that image
automatically you pass that image to the
vision API and you can understand what
the objects are within that image
automatically and you can figure out
where the faces are and it can tell
different people for the video
understanding API you can pass it the
video and it can tell scene transitions
different objects within that video you
can basically search and find what
you're looking for within the video or
across videos if you're passing multiple
videos OCR often people have documents
that they've scanned and you need to
kind of understand what the heck is in
that document maybe
PDF message if whatever it is you need
to be able to not Jeff in JPEG you might
pass it into the API and then it will
automatically detect what are the what
are the words in that document and give
you that raw text afterwards or what
maybe you've got an image of a scene and
there's signs on the wall it'll give you
the the text of what's on that sign
so the OCR is really really handy in
everyday applications the adult content
one is actually one really really
important because you might get
user-submitted content you don't know
what's in that image you need to make
sure that you're not presenting an
inappropriate image to your users so the
adult content is detection is a really
easy way for you to detect you know
what's going on in the image and is that
something you should filter out for your
users for the conversation class of API
is the audio decks you might have a
streaming audio file that you then need
to figure out what is being said
it will then transcribe that event and
give it to you it's useful for videos
for real conversations with people for
TV shows whatever it might be the
reverse is also possible you might have
a text string that you need to read out
to your user
well you pass the the string to the the
application and it will then create the
synthetic voice that you can then read
off to your user chatbots
is a way for you to engage with your
users and program the interactions you
would like in chat directly with your
user and program certain kinds of
conversations to go on and help them
with customer service calls or things
like that from the language ap is one of
the things that's really hard is if you
got freeform text what the heck is that
really saying we will map out and figure
out the the context of what it's saying
map out the data structure of the
sentences give you the parts of speech
so you can figure out okay what are the
nouns what are the verbs what are the
relationships of these and then you can
do something intelligent with that
structure sentiment analysis is a
situation where what's the mood that's
being transmitted along with those words
what we've had is we've seen a lot of
good success trying to monitor for
instance the sentiment of customer
service emails or chats and when things
are getting out of hand being able to
escalate that to manager so you can kind
of make sure
things don't spiral out of control or if
you need to understand if something's
aggressive or calm or happy how do you
kind of make sure you're categorizing
things appropriately if you're like
rating some customer service calls
things like that in translation it's a
great way to just automatically
translate from one language to the other
and we'll talk a little bit about that
next as an example so for instance say
you are a game developer and you have an
online community and they're but they're
coming from all over the world speaking
different languages you want them to be
able to talk to each other in real-time
chat you can basically have the ability
to translate to any of the other
languages so the Translate API makes
that really easy or you might be able to
get inbound customer service emails and
be able to translate that to a language
that your customer service rep
understands so that they can then find
the right article to respond to your
customer so the nice thing about these
api is they're basically just REST API
so basically we give you a snippet of
code you pop it into your your app the
only thing you really have to change is
the key and the URI to point to your
data and voila off you go
can't really get any simpler than that
the the other nice thing about this is
well the next question that comes up is
well what about performance how well do
these actually work they work really
great for common use cases for some
cases you might have a problem that
Google's never had to deal with or you
might have to deal with a situation that
with a lot more detail than Google has
to deal with for instance Google would
probably tell the difference between a
bolt and a nail really easily but if say
let's say you're a manufacturer and
they're you've got two thousand
different bolts on your production line
how do you tell the difference between
these for your parts well what we have
enabled is a cloud auto ml so you can
provide images of all of your parts
labeled and we may not be able to
distinguish them unless you give the
labels we then train a model for you
well then you get a REST API endpoint
that you can then use in your
application so the nice thing about that
is it's really easy to use and you don't
have to know machine learning we do it
for you but then you can use it in your
application so the next question is well
how well is this work it actually works
better than all the open-source models
out there and so you get a great
performing model and it's really easy
so it's been really helpful so the so
that's actually one category of way to
use ml another way is let's say I've got
data scientists and I want to build my
own model because I've got my own data
and it's a custom problem that I need to
deal with well there's two different
ways to do this one is using the cloud
manage services and these are services
where you don't want to deal with the
infrastructure we'll deal with that for
you that way you can focus on your
machine learning processes so we've got
data frock and data flow so you can deal
with your pre processing data proc is
essentially Hadoop and spark but managed
or dataflow is using beam in the back
end from a machine learning processing
perspective machine ml engine or machine
learning engine allows you to
automatically spin up the infrastructure
and we'll get to that in a little bit
and then tear it down when you're done
so it makes the it takes the
infrastructure pain away from the data
scientists it supports all the top
frameworks and we've got data lab which
is a managed notebook which allows you
to make the the data exploration easier
so first about data lab how many of you
out there have actually used Jupiter
notebook or know about Jupiter no books
so probably about a third of you or half
so just for the rest of you so you
understand what Jupiter notebook is it's
essentially an app where you can supply
a you can point it to your data and
supply some code to be able to analyze
your data visualize the data push return
see it immediately get some feedback and
then iterate on that and keep it all
ready and keep adding it to it you can
replay the entire notebook you can just
play certain snippets of that you can
share it with your coworker so it's a
really great way to explore visualizing
prototype so it's a fantastic tool the
nice thing about data lab is it's
pre-configured to connect to all the
different cloud services like bigquery
ml engine etc so it's really easy to
just work off of the cloud you can also
use it locally on your laptop machine
learning engine is really a great way to
do distributed learning on any arbitrary
data side for your data using all the
top frameworks and again it's it's a
managed service so you just point it at
your model and your data and you just
spin it up it takes care of all the
distributed training for you
don't worry about it terminate stairs
everything down is you only pay for what
you use so it's a really efficient way
to do this you don't have to worry about
accidentally leaving that VM on and
you're getting charged four months worth
doesn't notice when you get the bill the
other nice thing about this is it also
does batch prediction and online
prediction so basically you can spin up
these these batch prediction jobs really
efficiently or for online prediction it
will create that REST API endpoint for
you for your model and serve to whatever
volumes you need for any set of any
number of apps that you've got so it's a
great way to manage your apps in a
really easy way the other thing is we
found that data scientists often don't
do optimization of their models because
it's kind of a pain you have to you know
vary all the different parameters and
find the right configuration for your
data set well we've built that into ml
engine so it actually makes it really
simple for you you just give the
parameters and it will then go find the
optimal model so instead of finding just
a good enough model you're actually
finding the best one for your for your
data set so it really improves your
performance of your models so putting it
all together from a managed perspective
we've got different services - for every
step of the entire ml lifecycle that you
might have to deal with for an
application we've got the ingestion side
the pre-processing side storage in the
exploring and experimentation the
visualization side training and serving
your models or to be able to create
reports using data studio all of it on
our manage services you don't have to
deal with the infrastructure you don't
have to have an SRE managing all of
those pagers
the other way to do this is doing it all
yourself and rolling your own solution
there's actually some very valid reasons
why some customers would want to do this
you might be a researcher and you want
to be able to make changes to any part
of the stack you want it might be that
you've got a very custom pipeline or it
could be that you want cutting-edge open
source software to plunk in at any point
you want there's lots of different
reasons you might want to do that that's
completely okay we love users like that
you might also have a hybrid
implementation where some stuff is on
the cloud and some stuff is on Prem
that's a very common use case we want to
support that so doing it yourself and
having a way to deploy that is really
important
so the exact same infrastructure that we
had before which is managed the same
kinds of open-source platforms are
available it's for you to roll
automatically on your own infrastructure
you manage it and you get the exact same
hardware that's powering the other
solutions so we also make it really easy
to get started with deep learning you
know as deep learning has really been
taking off as a really great way to find
the insights and complex datasets and we
provide a VM image that's been certified
and optimized to work on GCE so out of
the box you get a jupiter notebook you
get access to all the hardware that
chris is going to talk about in a moment
and it's configured to get you the best
results possible so with one click you
can deploy this onto the machine of your
choice getting access to any
accelerators that you want and off you
go it's instant ready to go you know we
mentioned about the commitment that
Google has to the open source community
Kubb flow is a open source project that
I love it started last fall as a way to
on kubernetes be able to create micro
services for specific emiltt jobs like
distributed training or distributed
serving of different kinds of models
anywhere you want whether it's on GCP or
on Prem so this is a highly portable way
to deploy these containers everywhere
you want and that way your deployments
are consistent from GCP or run from and
you don't have to worry about the
resource matching because kubernetes
takes care of that it's a kubernetes
native way of handling all of that and
again it's configured to work on CPU GPU
and CPU on on GCE on Prem you get access
to whatever you have internally so how
that might look if you deploy that on
GCE would be you would you would create
your GE gke cluster which is a managed
kubernetes cluster on G on GCP you would
then be able to spin up your Jupiter hub
notebooks spin up your tensor flow
training service or you know any other
framework that you wanted to put and
then do the same thing for your tensor
flow serving it would all have access to
your shared storage on GCP natural to
kubernetes so it's a great way to
actually do this
very portable manner that entire
container and can then be deployed
anywhere you want and it's a it's a
fantastic solution so now I'm gonna pass
the time on to Chris he's gonna talk
about hardware Thank You Justin so going
back to the takeaways being excited
about ml feeling confident that you
could implement ML Google Cloud and
google's AI focus makes us the right
partner for your ml workloads let's talk
about that really quickly just to
reiterate some of these things right if
you're a developer and you want to
implement ml you don't need to be an ml
expert use our API models get started
right away
low risk if those pre trained ml models
aren't to your liking or you need to do
something custom use a web browser with
Auto ml to create custom ml models
amazing super simple and if you are a
data expert or machine learning
scientist or domain expert we have the
great tools for your workloads as well
you can successfully implement ml on
Google cloud but let's talk about
compute and Infrastructure briefly and
how it relates to ml 80% of the recent
AI improvements and advances have been
attributed to more available compute
power but at a recent tensorflow event a
survey is found that people admit not
having access to enough compute for
their ml research that's a clear problem
so let's go back a few decades because
all of us in this room working on ml
we're standing on the shoulders of
giants neural networks and this concept
of how ml works
it's decades old taking a look at the
human brain and how neurons are
connected to each other and how I
passing one information from one neuron
to another
it's an old concept but it's the recent
implementation of large-scale data
centers and hardware accelerators that
have been able to enable the us to make
these big neural networks and advances
M L so the infrastructure matters and
why it matters is no matter which path
you take building custom models using
Google mo models it's that
infrastructure that's holding it up in
our models we've already taken the data
pass it through a great algorithms and
pass it through this infrastructure
large scale football sized field data
centers over and over again to make
these models better and better we're
going to keep doing that and we with the
Google Cloud we're giving you access to
that same scale that same power to do it
yourself and do it affordably one of our
new ml customers on GCP is open ai and
talk about large scale they went the
unmanaged route they're a domain expert
they're an AI thought leader and they're
a nonprofit organization working on
innovating with AI and making it open
and safe they use a hundred thousand and
more processors to do reinforcement
learning they're using thousands of GPUs
to do machine learning it's that access
to scale that it's enabling enabling
them to innovate and it's Google cloud
that's providing it for hardware
accelerators are so important and just
hardware innovation with CPUs we have
skylake but for ML workloads we also
need for distributed training and large
training jobs we need paralyzed compute
power so we have historically since
February 2017 we've launched three
NVIDIA GPU models the K ATP 100 V 100
its high-performance passed through PCI
with and with the V 100 we have n V link
interconnections right super gray from L
workloads the one thing that we make it
a little different than some of our
competitors is how we offer custom VMs
take any amount of CPU any amount of
memory whatever GPU type you have any
number of GPUs create a VM use network
attached storage or if you want fast
disk i/o for a certain workload
attempted in server SSD and just pay for
what you want or if you have a
bottleneck a
just one of those some of our other
competitors don't offer that flexibility
so you save money and your animal jobs
gonna go faster actually going back one
this week we also launched the P for GPU
brand-new it's coming out in a week
it's great for ml inference workloads so
we're gonna keep working with our
partner Nvidia to launch new GPUs so we
don't just stop there
right I focus on Google we have the TPU
line right we made cloud v2 TPU
available last year
it's an ASIC purposely built for machine
learning and today we've made some new
amount announcements v3 coming out
faster cheaper ml workloads
there's the TPU pod which is a series of
TPU is connected with a fast network so
again google's AI focus is building
infrastructure we're training these ml
models quicker and we're also offering
it to you you should trust that we're
the right partner for you ml workloads
savings is a lot of money a big big deal
for a lot of companies there's an
assistant professor in Stanford who has
a budget does some research and ml and
he has a fixed you know only so much you
could do so there's a win-win product of
the unknown manager out preemptable VMS
and printable GPUs and CPUs sometimes we
have some spare capacity and ml batch
workloads like training and inference
it's we offer 70% off GPUs and TP use
and announced this morning we lower the
prices of TP use so now this researcher
could use our spare capacity get some
savings we run a batch workload it's not
for all use cases because the capacity
isn't guaranteed it's not always there
but if you're a research and you need to
do some work or a big organization that
just needs batch workloads once in a
while that's a great way to do more
innovation with less money data is
really important with ml Google has a
great fiber network great internet
connections so if you're moving your
data large chunks in we have it handled
if you have a large
real-time incoming flow of data through
various sources right we have cloud
locations all over the world if you need
to ship us some data we have an
appliance we can get you to ship large
amount it's not just compute it's not
just the great AI services it's the
network it's the security it's
everything built in there so we talked
about a lot of a s services giving you
an overview and an intro we talked about
how ml is not about inventing the
impossible it's about reimagining and
reinventing what you're doing today
there's over 14,000 customers doing ml
on GCP today so with our focus on open
and hybrid and multi-cloud workloads our
focus on hardware our new services that
we're announcing and the keynotes you
mentioned new auto ml services high
quality KPIs
doesn't matter how you want to do it
should feel excited that you could do it
you feel confident that you can
successively do it and Google is the
right partner for you there's a bunch of
ways you can learn more get started get
built one I'll call out specifically
that I personally used was cattle cattle
is an m/l competition service and
community when I was learning ml I
joined didn't know what I was doing
right there was an image recognition
competition where drivers were either
paying attention to the road or feeling
distracted so I joined the community I
joined the ml challenge they had a lot
of resources about how to use 10 to flow
and how to pre-process the data and
Google is using Kaggle to help the
people in the world learn ml and you too
could use it or if you're an
organization there's a bunch of data set
you can start a competition and have the
world ml experts - ml for you there's a
bunch of resources on how to learn about
these services there's free credits if
you're not a Google cloud customer
already
so with that we wanted to thank you our
time is almost up we're going to do some
Q&A so there's two mics on the other
side and just ask some questions thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]